Let's examine when the momentum
of a system is constant,
and apply that to
solving problems.
First, we'll revisit
the impulse equation.
On the left, we
have the impulse,
the integral of the total
external force acting
on a system between some
initial and final times.
And on the right,
we have the change
in the total momentum
of the system,
between those initial
and final times.
In a situation where
the impulse is 0,
we have that the change
in the momentum is 0.
P initial is equal to p final.
In other words, the
momentum of the system
is constant between some
initial and final time.
This is a vector equation.
But in many problems, we can
set up our coordinate system
so we only have to
consider one dimension.
Here's a simple example
of one block moving along
a horizontal surface with
some initial velocity,
colliding with a block at rest.
And then the two blocks
stick together and move.
Is momentum constant
during this collision?
To answer that question,
we need to think
about what our system is.
Let's look at the system
of both blocks together.
We can see the external forces,
gravity and the normal force,
add up to 0.
So our total
external force is 0.
During the collision, each block
exerts a force on the other.
But that is an internal
force if both blocks
are included in our system.
You can see that if our system
was just one of the two blocks,
we would need to know the
collision force in order
to solve for the final speed.
Therefore, we will
choose our system
to be the two blocks together.
We then need to set up
a coordinate system.
We'll pick the origin here, and
this direction to be positive
x.
Now we need to identify the
initial and final states.
Our initial state will be just
before the blocks collide.
The momentum of the
system is the sum
of the momentum of each
block individually.
We have m1 times v1 initial
x times i-hat plus m2 times
v2 initial x times i-hat.
This second term is 0, since
block 2 starts at rest.
The final state is right
after the collision
when the two blocks
are moving together.
They have the same velocity,
so the final momentum
is m1 plus m2 times v
final x times i-hat.
This gives us an
equation that will
allow us to solve for whatever
quantity we are not given.
Now let's look at a similar
collision, one that's
happening in two dimensions.
If we have one block
coming up from the bottom,
hitting one that's
coming in from the side,
I'll choose my unit vectors to
be like this, my origin here.
The momentum equation
gives us two equations,
one along the x
direction and the other
along the y direction.
Once again I'll choose
the initial state
to be just before the
collision and the final state
to be just after the collision.
The momentum in
the initial state
is again the sum of the momentum
of each block individually.
And the momentum
in the final state
is the mass of the two
blocks added together
times the velocity
of the two blocks.
Notice that this velocity
has a component in both
the x and the y directions.
Again the total external
force on the system is 0.
So the impulse is 0 in both
the x and y directions,
and therefore, momentum is
conserved for both the x and y
components.
So I can write my two
momentum equations like this.
The impulse equation
is a vector equation.
So generically,
in two dimensions,
we will have two equations.
We always need to check that
the momentum is conserved
in each direction separately.
And it is possible to
have a case where momentum
is conserved in one
direction but not the other,
if we have some net external
force in one direction.
What would happen if, in
our 1d collision example,
the blocks now experienced
friction along the surface?
Can we still assume that
the momentum is conserved?
In fact, if we pick a point in
time right before the collision
and compare that to a point in
time right after the collision,
we can see that the
impulse from friction
is over such a short
period of time,
that the impulse
is really small.
And we can say that the momentum
is approximately constant.
If we consider times later,
after the collision is over,
then momentum is
certainly not conserved,
which is what you would expect.
You'll see the two blocks
slow down due to friction.
So even if there are other
forces acting on the system,
like friction or
gravity, we can still
calculate the result
of a collision
as if the momentum is
constant during the collision
by picking times only a
very small delta t apart.